[Musik]
prima Kleber fliegen zum Badeurlaub nach
balija wer will das nicht trotzdem
großer Aufregung gleichzeitig soll immer
mehr Verbrenner aus den Innenstädten
verbannt werden wie passt das jetzt
alles zusammen das besprechen wir jetzt
mit Historiker und Autor Klaus Rüdiger
Mayer der die ökovision unseres
Wirtschaftsministers harbeckschaf
kritisiert und Deutschlands Zukunft es
Wirtschaftsnation gefährdet sieht der
neue Verteidigungsminister Boris
Pistorius hat die Wiedereinsetzung der
Wehrpflicht ins Spiel gebracht mein
Kollege bin Chef Reporter Peter Tide hat
selbst gedient und sie darin viele
Vorteile er fordert aber auch ein
Deutschland ja für alle wir fanpagei war
ein jungen Jahren sehr Salafist hat
Kämpfer für al-Qaida angeworben oder Tat
saß im Gefängnis und heute warnt er
unsere Politiker Vertrauen Islamisten
stellt sie zu bekämpfen wenn sie sogar
finanziell unterstützt
Verbrenner raus aus den Städten
Tempolimit damit machen die Berliner
Grünen Wahlkampf CDU-Politiker Stephan
eversschlick zurück das sei Polemik sagt
er und fordert freie Fahrt für freie
Bürger ja verstehen kann man es ja schon
Winterwetter Kälte wer will da jetzt
nicht lieber auf Bali am Strand liegen
ja dieses junge Paar hat genau das getan
obwohl sie eigentlich Gerichtstermin
gehabt hätten der Vorwurf der
Staatsanwaltschaft Störung des
öffentlichen Verkehrs ja viele Bürger
wohnen sich jetzt schon also diese
beiden gehören zur klimakleberbewegung
die sich schwer um die ärgerwärmung
Sorgen und das einen am liebsten das
Auto verbieten möchte dann aber fliegen
sie selbst ans andere Ende der Welt und
verbrauchen dafür rund 140.000 Liter
Kerosin überraschend ist es aber auch
wieder nicht auch andere Köpfe der Klima
Bewegung fliegen gerne mal um den
Erdball so z.B auch Luisa Neubauer von
Fridays for future die immer wieder ist
viel Fliegerin kritisiert wird Afrika
Asien Amerika für ihre Reisen Gil
Politikern als Langstrecken Luisa ja
Peter mit Blick aufs Wetter sind wir da
zu hart wenn wir die verurteilen die
jetzt sich aufmachen um im Bali einfach
mal am Strand zu legen nein wir sind
nicht zu hart wir sind eher noch zu
milde mit denen denn sie spielen sich
auf quasi wie ja wie alte Hexenjäger sie
wollen uns das Auto verbieten sie wollen
uns das Fliegen verbieten sie wollen uns
den Genuss verbieten sind einfach
radikal sie pfeifen auf Gerichte sie
pfeifen auf den Start sie pfeifen auf
die Polizei und sie pfeifen auch auf
Leute die einfach nur zu arbeiten müssen
und wer sich der hatte ich auch spielt
wer also die Moralapostel gibt wer also
wirklich sich jeden erhebt und meint die
Moral ist mit mir und deswegen ist mir
jedes Recht und jedes Mittel dann auch
gegeben der gehört dann wenn er nach
Bali fliegt ordentlich durch den Kakao
gezogen und wenn er auf der Straße klebt
auch abgerufen und weggesperrt jetzt
gibt's keine Begründung Sprecher der
letzten Generation verteidigt den Typ
und sagt sie haben den Flug als
Privatleute gebucht nicht als
Klimaschützer das muss man
auseinanderhalten Herr Mai kann man das
Trennen
sicher gibt es ein Privatleben und es
gibt ein Berufsleben jetzt ist die Frage
ob klimaschütze ein Beruf ist und
Feierabend mit Urlaub mit Vergütung mit
Krankenversicherungspflicht ist ja auch
ganz wichtig auch bei dem Wetter dann
könnte sich schnell erkälten also mit
anderen Worten es ist letztendlich die
Frage wie man das sieht aber und es gibt
ja auch Geld dafür dass darf man nicht
vergessen und zwar es gibt ein Fond man
wird dafür auch bezahlt und ich habe
jetzt gelesen man bekommt ein mittleres
Einkommen was man unter Mittel verstehen
mag nicht also nein ähm wenn man für
eine Sache steht und wenn man sagt ich
nehme das ab dann muss man das auch ganz
machen ansonsten ist es Heuchelei wie
sehen Sie das sind mit solchen Aktionen
die klimaaktivisten dann überhaupt noch
ernst zu nehmen für Sie
ja für mich ist es nicht ist es nicht
wirklich ernst zu nehmen vor allem so
Aktionen wenn man dann sieht ja Leute
die sich so als Rebellen aufspielen und
quasi eigentlich nur das machen was dem
Zeitgeist entspricht und dann noch
finanziert werden also für mich ist
irgendwie ihre billion oder irgendwie
anfangen von Missständen was ganz ganz
anderes und ich denke wir haben ganz
andere Probleme in diesem Land als ähm
ja solche sinnlosen Aktionen hier
durchzuführen sie leben in Wien na da
werden auch öfter mal die Straßen
blockiert wir reagieren sie denn da
würden sie im Stau stehen
ich glaube dass ich da schon eingreifen
würde und die Leute davon der Straße
wegtragen würde weil ich denke das ist
vom Recht gedeckt ja das ist eine ja ich
sag mal Behinderung im Straßenverkehr
mit manchmal auch verteilen Folgen gab
es ja selbst ein Todesfall
Verkehrsunfälle ich denke dass die
Bürger da ein bisschen mutiger sein
sollten und einfach mal ein bisschen
sind Zutat genau nicht auf die Polizei
[Musik]
also es kommt auf die Situation an aber
ich denke wenn ihr uns jemand sich
direkt auf die Straße stellt und
irgendwie den Verkehr behindert dass es
dann natürlich auch vom Recht
legitimiert ist zu sagen hier wir müssen
das wieder sicherstellen und solche
Störer einfach ja von der Straße tragen
wir waren auch bei dem Thema Doppelmoral
Herr was ist das ein bisschen ein
Zeichen unserer Zeit diese Doppelmoral
also das ist ja alles nicht ganz neu wir
haben die höchste suv-dichte im
Prenzlauer Berg dort werden noch die
Grünen am stärksten gewählt das eine hat
schon mit dem anderen zu tun wenn wir
uns auch anschauen wer sind denn
eigentlich so zur kulturell grünen
Wähler das sind die auch das Kleingeld
haben um in den Urlaub nach Bali zu
fliegen diejenigen die am Ende im Stau
stehen weil die Straßen blockiert sind
das sind diejenigen die gar nicht das
Geld für seinen Flug hätten und ich
glaube gerade diese Doppelmoral muss man
auch ansprechen aber das viel wichtigere
ist viele dieser Aktionen sind kriminell
und da ist auch der Rechtsstaat gefragt
hat durchzugreifen also man kann die
durch den Kakao sehen für seinen
Urlaubsflug wichtiger finde ich dass wir
sie im Knast zehn wenn sie solche
Straftaten begehen hätte ich das Peter
überrascht wundert Dich dass man im
Urlaub
auch überrascht weil die Szene ist so
das war früher in der linken Szene war
das Haar genauso Eigentum war Pest war
koderer gleichzeitig aber wir der Kumpel
hatte ein Auto ich war der mit dem Auto
dann wurde das Auto ausgeliehen da war
der Tank leer das Auto war irgendwie
dreckig Eigentum von anderen war immer
Mist wenn man selber in der Lage war
Eigentum zu haben dann war dann was
heilig man will immer das dann was man
will noch einmal kurz zu dem Punkt mit
das war privat das sind ja wirklich
abspaltungsprozesse die kennt man aus
der schamanischen Schwitzhütte oder vom
Kiffen aber die meinen ja den Quatsch
wirklich ernst die die weil sonst bricht
er ihre Argumentation zusammen diese
Helden die sich dahinten die großen
Kämpfer für die Freiheit für Gleichheit
die leben ja das absolute Gegenteil also
oben ist das Kapital und unten ist das
klebepräger die werden finanziert von
von reichen Hollywood mit Leuten von von
Erben vom
Ölstands finanzieren die und dann gibt
es so Leute wie Elisa Neubauer oder
kriter tun weg jetzt auch nicht aus der
Kinderarmut raus gerettet werden mussten
und unten haben wir denn Jannik und die
Luisa die jetzt auf Bali liegen die auch
mal dahin wollen wo die anderen sind die
sie finanzieren die ganze Szene ist wie
Gott das ist verlogen und wirklich also
da hat durchgreifen und ansonsten müssen
die normalerweise müssten die eigentlich
prominenten ignoriert wenn einen
wegnehmen Fahrstuhl frei machen dass
alle durchkommen den Rest einfach sitzen
lassen Fälle in der Politik kennst du da
welche wo du eine ähnliche Doppelmoral
siehst wo man das eine Predigt und dann
aber das andere tut ja die gibt's wenn
wir ganz ehrlich mit und mit uns selber
sind wie alle neigen ja zu Doppelmoral
wir alle halten uns ja nicht immer an
unsere eigenen Standards aber wir sind
ja nicht in der Politik wir gehen nicht
nach vorne also wird Journalisten
vielleicht noch wir kommentieren auch
manchmal vom Boden runter aber wer sich
so prominent in die Öffentlichkeit
begibt wer in der Politik entscheiden
möchte und wer den Leuten dann auch noch
vorschreiben will wie sie zu leben haben
und das ist nun mal die Spezialität
einer ganz bestimmten politischen Kaste
der muss sich dann auch daran messen
lassen und daran scheitern dann ein
schöner Regelmäßigkeit die diverse
Politiker und
auch Moralapostel wie ihr Frau Käßmann
die dann mit mit bedroht beim Rot über
die Ampel fährt oder andere Leute es
gibt genügend Politiker da ist die
einmal nachher sind voll damit daran
scheitern nicht nur normale Leute daran
scheitern vor allem Politiker auf dem
hohen Rost sitzen aktuell
fährt mir tatsächlich jetzt keiner ein
aber nee
der in Südamerika Urlaub macht darf man
sowas muss man der bessere Mensch sein
darf man sowas dann nicht tun also man
musste das andere predigen das ist doch
der entscheidende Punkt so äh ich habe
das jeder Mensch Merkel und Fehler hat
alles total in Ordnung und das jeder
Mensch ein widersprechen unterwegs ist
auch total in Ordnung aber man sollte
man sich nicht an die Spitze der
moralpyramide stellen und das ist das
was er generell das Problem
ehrlicherweise mit linker Politik gerade
mit grüner Politik ist ist es immer von
diesem Habitus geprägt ist wir sind die
guten wir sind die mit der besseren
Moral ihr seid die anderen die da unten
und ich glaube das diesmal auf die Art
und Weise jetzt auch deutlich wird dass
das tut der warte mal ganz gut
es gibt auch in diesem konservativen
konservativen Anspruch scheitern also
die dann nicht so konzentrieren kann
sie haben recht das ist diese diese
komplette Selbstüberhöhung ist ein
linkes Spezialität aber es gibt eine
besondere Begriff der das alles in und
zwar ziviler Ungehorsam also wenn ich
das Wort ziviler Ungehorsam höre dann
gehe ich fast die Decke hoch weil wenn
ich mich daran erinnere 1989 standen wir
auf der Straße und hätten auch Panzer
fahren können die sind Gott sei Dank
nicht gefahren und jetzt haben wir eine
Situation da sagt man Wir sind Helden
wir machen zivilen Ungehorsam und
erwartet aber das Ziel von der Polizei
geschützt wird das nicht Autofahrer
zornig werden oder oder es heißt sie
wieder Ungehorsam der im Übrigen ein
unrechtsbegriff auch ist man worauf man
sich in einer Demokratie dass zivilen
Ungehorsam bedeutet Berufen also
insofern ist dieser zivile Ungehorsam
eigentlich so eine eine
Selbstbeweihräucherung die man vor sich
herträgt und es bedarf eines zivilen
Ungehorsam eine funktionieren Demokratie
und die haben wir und da fällt mir
übrigens ein wie Gottes Beispiel ein und
zwar ja ähm immer wenn die wenn die
nehme ich die Demonstration von
rechtsextreme stattfinden oder von der
AFD die muss man alle nicht mögen ich
mag die auch nicht ich möchte auch nicht
hingucken ich möchte da auch nicht
stehen aber die haben verdammt noch mal
das Recht das grundgesetzlich geschützte
Recht auf freie Meinungsäußerung auf
Demonstrationsfreiheit und wenn die das
anmelden dann dürfen die das machen wenn
ich mich dann davor setze und die
blockiere und mich dann wie Gott da
Weise auf zivilen Ungehorsam Berufe also
quasi eine persönlichen moralischen
Notstand der ist mir jetzt erlaubt
anderen das Recht auf demonstrationsfrei
also Grundrecht zu nehmen dann muss ich
auch damit leben dass ich dahinter einen
Preis zahlen muss und in Berlin ist es
zum Beispiel mal passiert da saßen der
damalige Bundestagspräsident Wolfgang
Thierse in der ersten Reihe ein
Staatsvertreter gegen die Polizei hat
sich wegtragen lassen und das Gejammere
als aneinander es war glaube
schon wir waren 60 Euro glaube ich als
die gezahlt werden mussten war das
gekauft und Geheule groß nein wenn ich
schon für mich die moralischen Notstand
ausrufen und sage ich kann nicht ich
stehe hier und kann nicht anders ja
bitteschön da muss ich aber auch dafür
bezahlen dass mich zwei Polizisten
wegtragen mussten aber dieses wegtragen
das ist ja jetzt auch schon teils
sondern die Art und Weise in der bequem
noch vor die Kameras getragen wird damit
Frau Neubauer dann noch mal ihre
Interviews aus dem Polizei hat das ist
genau Teil des Problems und richtig ist
da wünscht man sich dann auch gleiche
Härte einen halben ist am anderen Orte
zu Amazon Wasserwerfer eingesetzt und
ich finde auch durchaus mal zurecht das
darf dann aber auch da passieren also
die Wünsche die Visionen halten wir fest
sind das eine die Realität ist ganz oft
das andere und das betrifft auch die
Energiefrage schauen wir uns erstmal
ganz genau an in Deutschland die
Regierung sind weiter auf ein neuerbare
Energie und gleichzeitig aber die
Kohlekraftwerke die laufen und laufen
und laufen Sie Herr mai sie sagen wenn
wir so weitermachen dann wird es vor
allem auch mit der Wirtschaft bergab
gehen ihr Thema ja also er Scholz ist ja
gerade zurückgekehrt aus Südamerika und
hat dort mit in Argentinien in Brasilien
und in Chile verhandelt
es ging natürlich um die Wiederbelebung
des Freihandelsabkommens aber vor allen
Dingen ging es um die Sicherung von
Rohstoffen die man auch braucht für den
Umbau der deutschen Wirtschaft nämlich
Rohstoffe wie Kupfer Lithium und dem
berühmten Wasserstoff er hatte nur
obwohl Robert Habeck ein großer Freund
vom grünen wasserstoff ist er hatte
Robert Habeck nicht mitgenommen und das
hatte vielleicht auch einen Grund gehabt
weil nämlich Robert Habeck hier in
Deutschland gerade sehr viel zu tun hat
wir laufen nämlich in eine große
eventuell Katastrophe gerade in Berlin
gerade in Ostdeutschland denn
wenn die Raffinerien in Schwedt und in
Leuna keine Treibstoffe produzieren dann
wird in Ostdeutschland kein Auto fahren
kein LKW fahren kein Flugzeug in vom ber
abheben und das Problem in der ganzen
Geschichte ist das dass man gesagt hat
wir wollen kein russisches Erdöl mehr
haben aber man hat nicht vorgesorgt
dafür was das was ist dann geht wie man
denn diese Lücke füllen kann und
interessanterweise stellt man sich das
jetzt gerade so vor im
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium also ein
bisschen spät kommt so ein bisschen Öl
aus Rostock an und irgendwann vielleicht
ein bisschen aus Danzig und irgendwann
vielleicht im März dann etwas aus
Kasachstan übrigens dann kommt wieder
Erdöl aus der druschbar aus der Pipeline
wir bezahlen dann nur
durchleitungskosten an Russland aber da
hat Herr Kellner auch gesagt das ist gar
nicht so schlimm das bezahlen die
Kasachen für uns das vielleicht dann das
Geld dann oben drauf geschlagen wird der
durchleistungskosten das hat er entweder
nicht gewusst oder nicht gesehen mit
anderen Worten schaut man sich die
Energie Situation an schaut man sich die
Situation an laufen wir in ein großes
Problem hinein denn und nur eine Zahl zu
nennen wenn man sich wirklich auf Polen
verlässt auf den Hafen in Danzig dann
kann dann sich 36 Millionen Tonnen im
Jahr umsetzen
und 30 Millionen Tonnen braucht allein
Polen dann bleiben noch 6 Millionen
Tonnen übrig und sowohl voll Auslastung
Schwedt voll Auslastung
Leuna sind jedes Mal 12 Millionen Tonnen
das heißt 24 Millionen Tonnen wir haben
also ein riesiges doch was die
Versorgung von Erdöl betrifft und das
hat was zu tun mit der Utopie von Robert
harek der glaubt dass es alles nicht so
wichtig wir brauchen das eigentlich
alles nicht mehr wir wollen all electric
wir wollen alles umstellen auf
E-Mobilität wir wollen unbedingt das
hinbekommen dass wir nur noch
Wasserstoff haben wenn mal die Sonne
nicht scheint der Wind nicht weht und
deswegen interessiert mich das alles gar
nicht und was mich an Schwedt
interessiert denke ich gesagt habe ist
eigentlich nur dass wir dort auch ein
zusätzlichen Standpunkt haben für unsere
neuere wasserstoffindustrie
zu machen und auch um ihre These jetzt
nicht nur in im Osten Deutschlands zu
lassen sondern mal auf unser gesamtes
Land zu beziehen sie glauben also in der
Energiepolitik darin wie derzeit eine
Sackgasse rein ja das denke ich schon
weil ähm warum haben wir gehabt was ist
der ganze Kern des Streit zum Rad es ist
was ganz einfaches und zwar sagt man
erstens wir wollen ähm wir wollen die
erneuerbaren Energien
wir als Backup Gaskraftwerke die wollen
wir nicht mehr mit Erdgas
bedienen sondern mit Wasserstoff
deswegen brauchen wir eine Infrastruktur
für Wasserstoff Gaskraftwerke Netz etc
pp bis zum Jahr 2030 wollen wir das
geschafft haben dann bis dahin haben wir
eine Energie Lücke das soll jetzt durch
die Kohle
gefüllt werden denn wir haben ja zu
wenig Erdgas also muss müssen es die die
müssen uns die Kohle Verstromung sein
Kernkraft wollen wir nicht warum wollen
wir keine Kraft das ist auch ziemlich
einfach denn Kernkraft ist wie
Wasserstoff eine Zukunftstechnologie und
es könnte sich ja vielleicht
herausstellen dass sie Kernkraft die
wesentlich zukunftsfähigere Technologie
ist sondern wenn man sich auch keine
Konkurrenz in dieser Geschichte machen
heißt mit anderen Worten nutzfahrt muss
weggebaggert werden damit bis 2030 die
Energie Lücke gedeckt wird weil man
glaubt 2030 ist man dann immer in der
Utopie
neben mir und ich bin mir sicher Peter
du möchtest bei diesem Thema schon
einiges ergänzen ich mach was total
verrücktes ich verteidige Robert Habeck
glaub mir kein Mensch also Robert Habeck
kann für die Abhängigkeit
Ostdeutschlands von russischen Öl und
von russischen Gas überhaupt nichts das
ist gegen die Grünen passiert das ist
halt passiert von ostdeutschen
Politikern die sehenden Auges 30 Jahre
lang eine pro russische und auch eine
prokreme Politik gemacht hat die haben
sich teilweise kaufen lassen ihre
landesfallen Verbände lebten davon dass
sie von Russland unterstützt worden sind
das war ein Manfred Stolpe das waren
Matthias Platzeck das waren Herr
Sellerie und das waren Frau schließlich
und das war Herr Kretschmer unten in
Dresden wir können die ganze Pipeline
die die ganze Nord Stream Pipeline wie
sie dann durch Deutschland durchläuft
durchgehen und die gesamte Strecke war
gekauft und die war voll mit
kremlobbyisten und das geht bis nach
niedersachsenrand dafür kann Robert habe
ich nichts das heute noch Öl in der
ankommt trotz eines ähm das liegt an
Robert habe dafür gekämpft das kann man
ihm nicht angreifen man kann ihn ganz
ganz viel man kann ihn eine völligude
Windkraft Politik an ankleiden man kann
ihm eine völlig ein völlig cooles
Verhältnis und fast schon ein ein
heiliges Verhältnis gegen die Kernkraft
an angreifen man kann ihm angreifen
dass ihr jetzt das ganze Land zu
Spargeln will ohne dass noch
irgendjemand irgendwo eine
Umweltverträglichkeitsprüfung machen
will ohne dass die Bürger noch beteiligt
werden das kann man ihm alles angreifen
man kann ihn nicht angreifen das
lützerat-up abgebaggert wird lutzerat
ist ein Kohle Kompromiss statt fünf
Dörfern wird nur noch eins abgebaggert
und statt und der gesamte Kohleausstieg
ist auch dann Robert habe fällt mir so
schwer wie mir das Feld 10 Jahre
vorgezogen dafür fällt nur lützerat und
vier Dörfer fallen da da finde ich aber
das Schwedt wir müssen jetzt leider mal
auch unsere Zuschauer in den alten
Bundesländern mit ein bisschen
Ostdeutschland äh Nerven Schwedt ist zu
über 80% im Besitz eines russischen
Staatskonzerns und das ist erst passiert
mit der großen Erhöhung der Anteile kurz
vor dem Ukraine kriegt kurz vor dem
Überfall da haben Länder die wie
Brandenburg und Minister die nicht grün
waren zugelassen dass sich die Russen da
noch weiter einkaufen konnte dass ein
der Putin mit seiner kriminellen Kamera
da noch richtig irgendwie melken konnte
90 Prozent unseres Benzins in Berlin und
in Umgebung kommt aus kommt aus Russland
das ist russendiesel den wir jedes mal
tanken und ich möchte das nicht und wenn
es auf 15 teurer ist und Robert Habeck
hat das in dem Fall wirklich nicht zu
verantworten
sie haben eine große Wanne genommen und
alles reingeworfen und jetzt gucken wir
mal was in der Wanne alles liegt erstens
die wir können natürlich gerne
Geschichte betrachten das wird uns jetzt
in der jetzigen Situation nicht helfen
doch das nein es hilft nicht es hilft
nicht weil sie bekommen mit
Geschichtsbetrachtung kein Erdöl Problem
gelöst in diesem Moment sie bekommen
kein Kraftstoff produziert mit
Geschichtsbetrachtung sondern sie müssen
dann damit hier auch noch Fahrzeuge
fahren damit das funktioniert ich weiß
gar nicht wie sich das vorstellen wenn
die ausfallen aber gut dann müssen
Tankfahrzeug kann aus Polen kommen
Tankfahrzeug kann auch die alten
Bundesländern kommen also das kommt
ausgerechnet wie viel Punkte brauchen um
Leuna zu versorgen mit Erdöl von und das
funktioniert nicht es funktioniert nicht
es ist irgendwie krank waren können sie
gar nicht auf die Straße stellen kaputt
einfach kaputt gegangen ja nein das ist
schön ich meine moralisch ist das
wunderbar was sie sagen und moralisch
könnte ich mir auch die Hände daran
wärmen nur trotzdem davon wird kein
Liter Benzin Entstehen von all dem was
sie gerade gesagt haben wird kein Liter
Benzin produziert kommt kein Liter
Benzin an die Tankstelle und was ich von
einer Regierung erwarte ist nicht auf
die Vergangenheit zu schauen sich nicht
vor Historikern oder nicht Historikern
entschlanken Fuß zu machen sondern was
ich erwartet weit schauen zu denken weil
schon zu denken was mache ich jetzt mit
dieser Situation die ich habe wie gehe
ich damit um was habe ich für
Lösungsmöglichkeiten und die
Lösungsmöglichkeiten sind nämlich sehr
schwierig denn Widerspruch an der Stelle
natürlich könnte man sagen wir beziehen
das Erdöl dann über den Hafen Rostock in
dieser Woche hat das Ministerium das
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium
ganz klar gesagt wir bauen keine zweite
Pipeline nach Rostock stellen einfache
Frage möchten Sie dass wir in der
Situation weiterhin Gas und Öl aus
Russland kaufen
ich wäre sehr dafür gewesen zu sagen
lasst uns mal überlegen wie wir damit
umgehen wie schaffen wir Alternativen
was hat denn Frau was hat denn Frau
Werbung gemacht Frau Berger hat in Riga
gesagt wir wollen nichts mehr haben und
sie wussten die nur in diesem Moment
überhaupt nicht wie das gewährleistet
werden kann das ganze wie man überhaupt
eine Idee hat das Land zu versorgen wir
sind ein in eine Industrienation wie
wollen Sie das hinbekommen natürlich
können Sie fragen wollen sie das von da
haben nein Sie können dann sagt auch das
Kind ja also diese esse dieses Essen
will ich nicht das habt ihr nun davon
dass ich verhungere sie müssen eine
realistische Politik machen realistische
Politiker sie sind gerade im Wahlkampf
hier in der Hauptstadt und ich kann mir
vorstellen dass viele Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auch Diskussionen wie diese
verfolgen und sie fragen ja weiß ich
jetzt auch nicht für mich ist wichtig
das ist irgendwie bezahlbar ist und das
ist der Regierung vertrauen kann dass
das in guten Händen ist und man sich
kümmert wird dieses Vertrauen gerade
verspielt spüren Sie das sie sind jetzt
gerade viel auf der Straße unterwegs
Benzin auf jeden Fall dazu das ist hier
deutlich teurer als in anderen Regionen
und das hat natürlich mit der Situation
in Ostdeutschland zu tun das hat mit der
Infrastruktur zu tun die einfach mal
jetzt nicht in der Art und Weise
bereitgestellt werden kann weil die
Liefersituation sich verändert hat Punkt
die wird sich absehbar aber auch nicht
verbessern wir werden Lösungen finden
müssen die ohne Russland funktionieren
und zwar aus guten Gründen und aus
tiefer innerer Überzeugung müssen wir
das tun die Frage ist wo will ich dann
anschließend hin die Frage ist ja
richtig gestellt noch ist Wasserstoff
dann die Lösung das würde ich gerne
glauben wenn ich gleichzeitig sehe dass
in Berlin eine wasserstoffinfrastruktur
aufgebaut wird das ist aber ein echter
Transformationsprozess der auch mit der
Schaffung von neuen Arbeitsplätzen
verbunden sind aus Deutschland dann
stattfindet da sind wir aber in den
Ansätzen da gibt's noch gar keinen Plan
in der Schublade und das übrigens kann
man einen habe ich zum Vorwurf machen
das kann man auch den Grünen zum Vorwurf
machen denn die erzählen dass Märchen ja
schon seit Jahrzehnten den kommt das
jetzt quasi ideologisch gelegen wenn man
so will dass jetzt sozusagen aus Gründen
an der Stelle man über Alternativen viel
stärker nachdenken muss aber man hätte
kleine ja auch in der Schublade haben
können das heißt hier jetzt an der
Realität zu scheitern zeigt auch das
schon vom Ansatz sehr manche Ideen nicht
ausgereift ist und das ist das was mich
massiv ärgert man hätte in der Tat sehr
viel früher anfangen müssen auch
alternative und das sind wir bei
Pipeline Infrastruktur herstellen zu
müssen damit wir auch andere
Bezugsquellen erschließen können aber
das ist jetzt ehrlicherweise nicht der
Gesprächsstoff auf der Straße die
Menschen wollen dass das Problem gelöst
wird die verstehen ehrlicherweise nicht
warum wir jetzt nur über 49 Euro Ticket
diskutieren und nicht darüber dass auch
für Pendler was getan wird stärker da
erwarten Sie Antworten von der Politik
und ich glaube da sind wir gefordert und
jetzt weniger bei der Frage wollen wir
morgen den Haaren nach Russland wieder
auftreten da habe ich jetzt noch keinen
getroffen wenn sie so gesprächig zuhören
glauben sie manchmal verlieren wir uns
zu sehr verliert sich die Politik auch
zu sehr in Fachfragen und beantwortet zu
wenig die Fragen der Menschen
ja auf jeden Fall also ich will jetzt
nicht abstreiten dass das Thema Energie
sehr wichtig ist und dass es viele Leute
ja vielen Leuten Sorgen macht und auch
finanzielle Probleme macht wenn sie
nicht mehr tanken können und so weiter
aber ich sage wir stehen vor
vor anderen existenziellen Problemen die
die Bundesrepublik
bedrohen und das ist eben eines oder
mein Thema eben die Islamisierung die in
Deutschland stattfindet die Gefahr die
vom politischen Islam ausgeht ich sehe
für all diese Fragen sich ehrlich gesagt
auch eine Lösung ja weil ich meine wir
haben kluge Leute im Land wir haben
ja wir haben immer noch auch starke
Behörden und Experten und so weiter die
sich mit diesen Fachfragen
auseinandersetzen und wo man dann auch
ähm ja durch technische
Weiterentwicklung durch die Technologie
dann auch Lösungen findet aber auch
später noch mehr sie sind nämlich in
ihrem Thema dazu kommen wir auch gleich
die Preise beschäftigen natürlich viele
Menschen die jungen Menschen aber auch
die Rentner und die jungen Menschen
könnte vielleicht das ein Thema noch
mehr beschäftigen der neue
Verteidigungsminister Boris Pistorius
hat dazu die Tür aufgestoßen indem er
gesagt hat die Aussetzung der
Wehrpflicht die sei ein Fehler du Peter
du hast gedient du sagst das könnte
Vorteile bringen aber noch viel mehr als
das
auf der falschen Seite ich durfte heute
nicht also reservice eingezogen werden
ich habe auf der anderen Seite der Mauer
gestanden aber ich bin wirklich dafür
dass wir etwas machen dass ich
Deutschland ja annimmt da kann auch die
Bundeswehr mit dabei sein wenn dann
Leute gebraucht werden was muss
pistorisches jetzt gemacht hat war einen
Fehler einzugestehen öffentlich zu
benennen das hat in der politischen
Debatte dann immer zur Folge dass wenn
jemand sagt er wenn Fehler macht dann
macht sie rückgängig Christian Lindner
hat sich eingeschaltet Finanzminister
lieberale und der sagt das ist eine
Phantom gibt die Matte die alleinige
Debatte um die um die Wehrpflicht um die
allgemeine wirklich wie sie korrekt
heißt
die mag eine Phantom Debatte sein aber
ich finde ein Deutschland ja ein
freiwilligen Jahr für alle Jugendlichen
meinetwegen zwischen 18 und 25 je nach
lebens-situation das auch dazu führt
dass Jugendliche den Horizont erweitern
können ich kenne selber von meinem Sohn
der hat einen freiwilliges ökologisches
Jahr gemacht das hat ihn bei der Findung
auch auf seinem Berufsweg enorm etwas
gebracht und eine gemeinnützige Arbeit
sag mal so die hat noch nie geschadet
erweitert den Horizont und ein
Deutschland ja das auch z.B bei NGOs bei
Hilfsorganisation auch im Ausland
stattfinden kann das würde auch Kindern
die ausbildungsfernschichten oder aus
armen Elternhäusern kommen die nie einen
Auslandssemester machen könnten
ermöglichen einmal ins Ausland zu kommen
eine andere Welt kennenzulernen ihren
Horizont zu erweitern deswegen ist meins
Login Wehrpflicht muss nicht sein aber
in Deutschland ja für alle bitte sehr
eine Wiedereinführung der Wehrpflicht
wäre ja auch naja es fehlen Soldatinnen
und Soldaten was bedeutet das Peter
deiner sich nach jetzt vor allem in
dieser Situation mit dem Krieg in
Ukraine also die Bundeswehr hat nach dem
Aussetzen der der allgemeinen
Wehrpflicht 2011 die Strukturen so
geändert dass du ihn nicht sofort wieder
darauf zurückkommen könntest das würde
Jahre dauern die gesamten Strukturen
auch die unterbringungstrukturen in den
Kasernen dahin gehen zu ändern aber
es schadet nicht wenn wir mehr junge
Leute haben die freiwillig und sei es
nur ein Jahr zur Bundeswehr wir gehen
bei uns fehlt auch in der Politik das
komplette Verständnis vom Militär von
der Bundeswehr wir haben ja fast nur
noch ungedehnt wir haben in vielen
Bereichen unserer Gesellschaft niemanden
mehr der Ahnung hat von der Bundeswehr
und wir Schlitten immer mehr in so ein
Szenario rein das Leute zur Bundeswehr
weltbeginn auch das Geld deswegen die
aus anderen Verhältnissen kommen und das
stimmt die Mischung teilweise nicht mehr
also die die sich für Waffen
interessieren die gehen dahin aber der
Rest bleibt in der Bundeswehr mal schön
fern es sei denn man kann Karriere
machen also auch Bundeswehr dass man da
auch hin kann so wie man früher auch
Zivildienst machen konnte aber ich
glaube ein Jahr in der Jugend ist nicht
verschenkt sondern ist auch ein Geschenk
an die Jugend man wird sich sofort
merken aber hinterhermeister
reden denn der Verteidigungsminister ist
nicht der einzige der diese Tür aufmacht
auch der Kanzler hat das Thema
angesprochen marie-ag Zimmermann läuft
da vorneweg und viele mögen sich fragen
ist das der Zeitpunkt wo man sich aktiv
die Frage stellt in der Regierung auch
ist Deutschland verteidigungsfähig
glaubst du dass diese Gedanken damit
reinspielen also das ist natürlich immer
eine Nebelkerze weil das ob wir
verteilungsfähig sind hängt jetzt nicht
davon ab ob wir fünf Rekruten auf dem
Hof haben oder sechs das ist komplett
nebensächlich sondern die guten brauchen
was zum ballern die brauchen was zum
fahren und die brauchen was zum Fliegen
und was zum Tauchen und an all dem
mangelt es uns fehlt ja uns also wir
haben eine doch mal so wie es ist wir
haben eine Rumpftruppe die mit und
unterwegs ist Eckernförde da kommt die
Familie meiner Frau her wenn ich da zwei
ungute sehen dann freut mich schon mal
das beide einsatzbereit sind können aber
beide nicht gleichzeitig rausfahren weil
es gibt nur ein Smoothie so also gibt
nur einen Koch an Bord so an solchen
Albernheiten schalte das Hubschrauber
können die können nicht fliegen deswegen
müssen wir ein riesen Programm fahren
und tatsächlich die Bundeswehr
auszurüsten das ist keine Aufrüstung das
ist eine Ausrüstung eine wieder aus der
Bundeswehr und man darf doch mal
verdammt noch mal von so einer
Wirtschaftsnation wie uns verlangen dass
wir einsatzbereit sind das scheitert
aber wirklich nicht an der nicht nicht
an der Wehrpflicht also die Wehrpflicht
ist da vielleicht ein i-Tüpfelchen das
Bürgern
die werfe ich das hier nur ausgesetzt
das heißt man könnte sie auch schnell
wieder einsetzen sicher hat man
logistische Probleme da stimme ich ihn
völlig zu ich halte die wehrpflichten
aber noch aus einem anderen Grund für
wichtig und zwar wir hatten mal diese
Vorstellung von Bürger in Uniform wir
hatten mal die Vorstellung das
Wehrdienst auch ein demokratisierendes
Element ist in unserem Land und das
haben wir alles aufgegeben und deswegen
glaube ich dass es auch wichtig ist und
Sie können und das ist wiederum meine
Auswirkung Erfahrung sie können auch
sehr schwer eine es geht auch aber sie
können sehr schwer eine Armee aus
wehrdienstleistungen gegen das eigene
Volk einsetzen das war ein Punkt warum
1989 ist auch unendlich abgelaufen ist
und deswegen bin ich ein Befürworter der
Wehrpflicht und ich das teilen wir die
Erfahrung ich habe es hast ich will das
nie wieder haben ich wollte das nicht
haben ich habe gelitten dabei und
trotzdem muss ich sagen es ist wichtig
sie kommt das Thema ausgerechnet jetzt
hoch das fragen sich glaube ich viele ja
es ist natürlich auch ein Problem wenn
sie an Armee haben die nicht mehr das
wenn Sie so wollen
dass das Land abbildet wenn sie
eigentlich immer mehr Leute haben die zu
mir gehen wo sie sagen also ich hätte
mir auch eine andere Durchmischung
gewünscht das ist ein großes Problem das
zweite Problem ist sie haben ja recht
mit der Ausrüstung aber wenn wir die
Ausrüstung haben und wir haben dann
keine fünf Rekruten die sie bedienen
haben wir auch ein Problem das heißt wir
brauchen in der Tat ähm eine Wehrpflicht
und ich bin nicht ganz so der Meinung
dass das freiwillige Jahr bedeutet man
muss aufpassen dass nicht die jungen
Leute jetzt ausbaden müssen was z.B in
der Pflegeversicherung anderes wo an
Fehlern geschehen ist deswegen das ist
ein sehr differenziertes Problem also
ich würde auch noch so weit gehen zu
sagen dass die Wehrpflicht auch eine in
produktionsmaßnahme sein kann weil ich
sehe das zum Beispiel in Österreich wo
noch die Wehrpflicht besteht da kommen
Migranten die in ihren
Parallelgesellschaften Leben zum ersten
Mal mit der einheimischen Bevölkerung in
Berührung ja dass sie dann eben
gemeinsam dienen und dann Leute aus sein
aus seiner komplett anderen Gesellschaft
Schicht dann auch kennenlernen und dann
auch einen Bezug zum Land entwickeln ja
die die Fahne tragen die Nationalhymne
mitsingen und daher bin ich auch ein
Befürworter und würde sagen es wäre
sogar eine
integrationsfördernde Maßnahme denn das
ist doch das Kernproblem das viele
migrantenvolle muslimische Migranten
sich überhaupt nicht mit dem Land
identifizieren können ja gerade hier in
Berlin oder auch in anderen in allen
deutschen Großstädten leben sie in ihrer
Parallelgesellschaft völlig unter sich
und kommen nicht in Berührung mit mit
den Werten dieses Landes mit der
einheimischen Bevölkerung und daher
würde ich sagen sollte man das auf jeden
Fall Deutschland befürworten und so
versuchen auch ja Migranten vermehrt
einfach einzubringen denn es gibt doch
auch Migranten die sich mit diesem Land
identifizieren und da können Sie das und
unter Beweis stellen und diesem Land
auch dienen ob er zu einem freiwilligen
Jahr oder direkt bei der Bundeswehr ich
finde das ist auch dann so eine
Unterscheidung wem die Loyalität gebührt
weil es ist natürlich ein massives
Problem wenn die meisten Türken im Land
hier Erdogan wählen mehr sogar
prozentuell als in der Türkei ja da
sieht man dass das deine Identifikation
mit der deutschen Gesellschaft oder mit
Deutschland überhaupt nicht
stattgefunden hat und ich finde die
loyalitätsfrage welchem Land bin ich
loyal für welches Land bin ich bereit es
notfalls auch zu verteidigen dann mache
ich eine Umfrage nur 18 % der Deutschen
die sagen sie würden ihr Land
verteidigen Herr ihr was das heißt doch
auch einfach ganz klar die wollen nicht
zur Bundeswehr da haben wir ein Personal
Problem das hat die Bundeswehr sowieso
wie übrigens alle unsere Staatsdienste
und ich glaube da ist generell auch das
Problem erstmal angesiedelt das geht ja
nicht nur um die Bundeswehr es geht für
meinen Begriff um all die Repräsentanten
des Staates geht auch um die Feuerwehr
es geht um die Rettungsdienste die in
einer silvestern auf angegriffen werden
es geht um unsere Polizisten und viele
viele andere
Situation in Berlin in Berlin ist die
Bundeswehr ein Schulen unerwünscht in
Berlin die Polizei an Schulen
unerwünscht in Berlin ist unter dieser
Regierung gar keine Uniform an Schulen
erwünscht die gleichen Leute die jetzt
laut rufen man möge die Ukraine mit
Panzern unterstützen die gleichen Leute
die jetzt laut rufen man muss mehr für
die Bundeswehr tun habe über Jahre und
Jahrzehnte alles dafür getan dass die
Bundeswehr aber auch all diese anderen
Dienste mit Kredit geraten sind und
deswegen finde ich wichtig dass wir
diese Diskussion über ein
gesellschaftsjahr wie wir es natürlich
unendlich führen aber wir können schon
jetzt eine Menge tun ohne dass wir diese
langwierige Maschine einer neuen
Logistik für die Bundeswehr und alles
was dazugehört aufziehen und ich glaube
schon an der Schule angefangen müssen
einfach bewusst sein dafür schaffen in
was für einem Staat wir leben welche
Menschen diesen Staat welche Rolle sie
dafür eigentlich auch um welche
Verantwortung sie tragen das spielt die
Bundeswehr eine ganz maßgebliche Rolle
und wie wir uns in diesem Parlament
gezofft haben gerade mit grünen in der
Frage hat die Bundeswehr noch eine
Daseinsberechtigung und mit diesem
Parlament meine ich in Berliner Landtag
unser Abgeordnetenhaus das kann man
heute gar keine mehr erklären weil die
gleichen grünen von von andererseiter
als Kriegstreiber beschimpft werden weil
sie jetzt auf einmal sagen okay wir
müssen eine Ukraine militärische
unterstützen um das mal um das mal
übrigens Schlusslicht im europäischen
Vergleich also kein anderes Land hat ein
so geringen Wert
nicht nur mit der Wehrpflicht zu tun
nochmal ich bin für solche Gesellschaft
18 % ihr Land verteidigen ich sag
tatsächlich weil sie die Bundeswehr
schlecht kennen weil die Bundeswehr
kennengelernt hat als Arbeitgeber wenn
sich das mal angeschaut hat wie sie
funktioniert wer von Soldaten Soldaten
hört was das eigentlich bedeutet wie
ihre
Erfahrungen sind ist die Bude quasi
keiner interessiert sich dafür keiner
kommt keiner sieht aus ich habe nicht
mal sagte ein Soldat ein gutes Image ja
aber wie läuft es denn wir haben ich sag
mal glaube ich finde der Bundeswehr die
sich Gedanken darüber machen wie spreche
ich junge Menschen an so aber wenn die
dann auf die Straße wollen wenn die an
die Schulen wollen wenn in die
Jugendclubs wollen dann heißt es euch
wollen wir hier nicht haben ihr seid
Kriegstreiber ihr seid militarristen und
das ist doch der Punkt an dem wir in
gesellschaftliches Problem haben das hat
mit der Wehrpflicht noch gar nicht zu
tun was hat damit zu tun deswegen
generell alles was Uniform trägt
konsequent und gerade von linker Seite
schlecht geredet haben und deswegen
haben wir auch auf vielen ebenso wenig
Respekt vor dem Start und genau diesen
Akteuren die Bundeswehr ist da ein
Problem aber gerade auch all die anderen
nicht genannt hat
zu dir persönlich würdest du es
befürworten wenn deine Kinder jetzt zum
Beispiel sagen wir wollen zur Bundeswehr
also wenn mein Sohn das gesagt hätte
klar also national folgt irgendwie davor
geschmissen da gilt der alte Spruch
meiner Mutter wenn du Offizier wirst
wirst du enterbt das war sadistisch das
mal das Gegenüber nicht aber was woran
es uns fehlt und wenn 18 % der
Bundesbürger da sind jetzt auf Frauen da
dabei die für die Bundeswehr noch gar
nicht in Frage kam nur sagen wir würden
unser Land verteidigen dann ist das vor
allem auch ein bisschen überhöht
fehlender Patriotismus uns liegt unsere
Nation auch aus geschichtlichen Gründen
die sonderlich doll am Herzen wir haben
ein gespaltenes Verhältnis soll Soldaten
sind regelmäßig diffamiert worden das
ist Militarismus das ist immer das Böse
Preußen das immer heraus beschworen wird
und während der corona-pandemie da haben
sie ja völlig recht er durfte in
Friedrichshain Kreuzberg kein Soldat in
Uniform in Statistik Bogen in eine
öffentlichen Behörde Berlins ausfüllen
das muss man sich mal überlegen die sind
ausgesperrt worden wie Leprakranke und
werden wenn wir so mit unseren Soldaten
umgehen wenn wir so mit den Leuten
umgehen die uns verteidigen sollen wenn
wir dann auch so umgehen mit den
Polizisten und mit den Feuerwehr
bedeuten dann müssen wir uns nicht
wundern dass der Staatsdienst
unattraktiv ist das ist auch eine
politische Frage da spielen ganz viele
andere Sachen rein aber als Bürger darf
man sein Land inzwischen doch auch
lieben und man darf es dann auch dafür
verteidigen weil wir leben zwar in einem
Land das momentan und seit Jahren sehr
viele Fehler macht aber wir leben immer
noch in einem gut laufenden in einem
wohlhabenden Land und wir leben in
Frieden und in Sicherheit ganz kurze
Pause spannende Diskussion und dann sind
wir hier bei 8:15 Uhr mit diesem Thema
zurück lässt sich die Politik von
Islamisten hinters Licht führen wir
freuen uns wenn Sie dran bleiben bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig
realitätsfernsehen unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
was sie da vorne
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und Herr Bruder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel wenn die alle
wegfallen und wir uns gegenseitig in
Berlin Mitte Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand das ist alles essen als
Freiheit würde ich sagen das muss jedem
erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
bei viert schön dass ihr bei uns sitzt
Herr pichi ihr Leben kann man sagen
könnte fast ein ganzes Buch füllen ein
eigenes großes Buch ihre Geschichte sie
geboren sind sie in Serbien und dann
sind sie jungen radikale Kreise gelangt
waren dann sozusagen Pressesprecher von
al-Qaida erklären Sie uns einmal was hat
Sie damals radikalisiert
was mich damals oder digitalisiert hat
und da werden wir jetzt auch schon beim
Thema ist das als ich in Deutschland
aufgewachsen bin also ich war zwei Jahre
alt bin in Deutschland aufgewachsen dass
meine Identität so ein bisschen
gespalten war ja man wusste nicht so
wirklich oder ich wusste nicht so
wirklich wo ich dazu gehöre und da
spielt eben dieser diese Verachtung die
wir im Land haben eine große Rolle denn
wenn man sich selbst schlecht redet wenn
man mit dem deutsch sein immer nur
Negatives verbindet dann ist es sehr
schwer für Migranten Teil dessen zu
werden und dann sucht man sich andere
Identitäten unter anderem eben im Islam
oder im radikalen Islam und sowas bei
mir auch als ich mir gewisse Sinnfrage
gestellt habe was bin ich Woge ich hin
und da bin ich dann leider in die Fänge
von radikalen geraten und bin dann
radikaler Moslem gewesen auch ja ihre
Geschichte ja weiter sie landeten im
Gefängnis und wurden dann aber auch noch
V Mann Mann erzählen sie jetzt einmal
wie für sie der Ausstieg kam kann es
durchs Gefängnis erst ja auf jeden Fall
also ich muss ehrlich sogar ehrlich
gesagt sogar sagen dass ich froh bin
dass ich damit inhaftiert wurde weil das
ein wichtiger Schnitt war und ich damals
dann eben in dieser Isolationshaft zum
ersten Mal raus war aus dieser wird
sagen fast schon mehr was sektenmäßiges
hatte was sektmäßiges an sich und ähm
dann eben durch Selbstreflexion durch
selbstkritisches Nachdenken zu dem
Entschluss gekommen bin dass ich mich da
verirrt habe und ich quasi zurück in die
Gesellschaft will und da ausstehe
aussteigen will und dann kam eben das
Angebot von Verfassungsschutz ob ich
denn meinen Ruf damals in
islamistenkreisen
dafür nutzen will verdeckt quasi als
Quelle in der Islamisten seine
hauptsächlich hier in Berlin zu arbeiten
und ich habe es als meine Pflicht
gesehen und ich muss sagen auch als eine
gewisse patriotische Pflicht dass ich
sag ich bekenne mich jetzt zu diesem
Land dann will ich auch mein Beitrag
leisten und benutz auch bereit eben mein
Leben dafür zu riskieren und das habe
ich damals eben gemacht als Quelle für
den Verfassungsschutz in der Islamisten
Szene hauptsächlich in Berlin aber
deutschlandweit natürlich auch das ist
also Ihre persönliche Geschichte sie
kennen sich in der Islamisten Szene aus
wie weniger muss man sagen und sie sagen
ganz klar jetzt kommen wir zu Ihrem
Thema die Politik die lässt sich da zum
Teil auch einwickeln das ist ihre Zeit
und ihre Kamera ja auf jeden Fall die
Politik lässt sich lässt sich da
einwickeln aber nicht nur die Politik
also ich würde sagen alle politischen
Parteien sind mittlerweile oder fast
alle hatten schon Islamismus Skandale
werden unterwandert nicht nur die
Parteien alle gesellschaftlichen
Bereiche im Bildungssektor in den Medien
egal wo wir hinschauen ne also andersrum
wäre es besser gefragt wo haben wir noch
keine Islamisierung und ich denke das
ist eine sehr sehr große Gefahr den wir
entgegentreten müssen und die einzige
Maßnahme meiner Meinung sind volle und
lang heißt nicht gedacht denn eine
Maßnahme ist ein Verbot des politischen
Islams wie es auch in der in Österreich
damals
innerhalb der ÖVP und
fpö-koalition auch geplant war nämlich
ein gesetzliches Verbot des politischen
Islams ist es eine extremistische
Ideologie die sich ja
Deckmantel einer Religion quasi tarnt
und versteckt und da eben die
Religionsfreiheit Meinungsfreiheit in
Anspruch nimmt und das ist denke ich die
Grundlage
die Grundlage einer einer Wende ja wir
reden immer über Symptome über Gewalt
Vergewaltigungen Anschläge
islamistische Unterwanderung und so
weiter aber ich sage wir können das
Problem nur an der Wurzel packen wenn
wir erstmal eine gesetzliche Grundlage
schaffen auf die dann Behörden Justiz
darauf aufbauen und dann reagieren
können und dann eben radikale Moscheen
dicht machen is politische Hassprediger
abschieben und dann erst überhaupt ja
gewisse Maßnahmen treffen um ihn zuvor
einer weiteren Islamisierung überhaupt
schützen zu können das also leere these
vor kurzem weil hier Hamed Abdel sama zu
Gast auch ein Kritiker der kann sich
nicht mehr frei bewegen der kriegt
Morddrohungen und die ganze Zeit Polizei
an seiner Seite standen hier auch vor
unserer Studiotür wie ist es bei ihnen
bekommen sieben Autoren
wurde als eine Quelle des
Verfassungsschutzes was jetzt
mittlerweile über 10 Jahre her ist
bekomme ich konstant Morddrohungen fast
schon täglich ja da finde ich immer so
ein bisschen ja
seltsam wenn wenn wenn jetzt
irgendwelche gewissen linken Politiker
dann mit einer Mail kommen und sagen ja
da wurde gedroht und dann wird er groß
mit dir darüber berichtet ich kann ihn
jetzt den Posteingang meines Instagram
Account zu zeigen oder kommt täglich
wirklich wirklich Nachrichten
ich bringe dich um du gehörst dir
umgebracht und so weiter also das
betrifft alle und Ab der Summit eben war
ja eben mit ja so präsent ist und ich
würde sagen der bekannteste
Islamkritiker im deutschsprachigen Raum
und daher Polizeischutz bekommen muss
ich habe auch eine Zeitlang
Polizeischutz bekommen ich habe ich beim
BKA Zeugenschutzprogramm also ich habe
das alles schon hinter mir und verzichte
aber bewusst da drauf weil ich sage wir
dürfen uns nicht mehr einschüchtern
lassen wir sind im eigenen Land wieso
soll ich mich jetzt hier nur mit Polizei
Schutz fortbewegen sondern es ist eine
Minderheit und es muss wirklich sein
sich auch als Islam Kritiker frei im
Land bewegen zu können und sich eben
nicht von der radikalen Moslems
einschüchtern zu lassen
die Partei in die Politik mit wem müssen
die reden sie sagen auch die reden mit
den falschen lassen sich da zum Teil
einwickeln sagen sie das ist ihre These
das heißt mit wem muss gesprochen werden
ja es gibt natürlich auch eine wachsende
Gruppe von ex-muslimen von Leuten die
dort hineingeboren wurden und sich dann
bewusst dafür entscheiden
auszusteigen aus dem Islam auch
auszutreten oder eben aus einem
radikalen Islam auszutreten und leider
was wir beobachten bei diesen ganzen
Konferenzen angefangen bei Islam
Konferenz aber auch in
unzähligen Kooperationen und Initiativen
wo die die als Partner z.B fungiert er
der verlängerte Arm des türkischen
Staates ähm ich war selbst als radikaler
Moslem in Moscheen er da wird ein
radikaler Islam gepredigt er unterstützt
der türkischen Kontrolle und hat sich
natürlich auch gewandelt mit der Zeit
und da sehen wir leider dass die Politik
immer drauf schaut
ja wer wer wer bietet sich als Partner
an wer macht einen guten Eindruck und
oft auch dann nicht mal auf die eigenen
Behörden hört ja wir haben mehrere Fälle
wo zum Beispiel der Verfassungsschutz
warnt und sagt diese Akteur gehört dem
ist im aktionsgeflecht der
Muslimbruderschaft und die Politik ist
einfach ignoriert hat nenne das sind
unsere Partner mit denen arbeiten wir
zusammen und teilweise sind sogar
Steuergelder dann zuschanzen über
Vereine und Linke NGOs und Stiftungen
und so weiter und das ist natürlich ein
massives Problem wenn die eigene Politik
nicht mal mehr auf die
Verfassungsschutzbehörden hat die
Politik der zum Teil zu blauäugig und
redet mit den falschen ja wir machen uns
das sehr seit Jahren zu leicht gerade
auf dieser Schiene gerade beim Ismail
ist Mensch
also gerade bei diesem Thema machen wir
uns das seit Jahren zu einfach wir haben
es immer gerne wenn wir an unseren
runden Tisch setzen können und da kommt
ein Vertreter von XY an dass sie Muslime
aber die haben ja nicht so eine Art die
haben keinen richtigen zentraler die
sind nicht organisiert wie die jüdische
Gemeinde oder anderen Gemeinden da
kannst du nicht mit einem Kopf reden
weil du weißt nicht wer da noch hinter
steckt und werde alles nicht am Tisch
sitzt da musst du wirklich an der Basis
arbeiten und da würde helfen wenn der
politische Islam einfach verboten werden
würde wenn die Finanzierung von Moscheen
aus von bestimmten Strukturen aus dem
Ausland unterbunden und verboten werden
würde und er würde es helfen wenn vor
Ort einfach wirklich da muss geredet
werden du musst vor Ort reden du musst
an den Schulen reden du musst in die
Vereine gehen du musst dahin gehen wo
die Leute sitzen du musst meinetwegen
auch in die Männer in die Männer Räume
gehen in diese Kulturzentrum reingehen
da musst Du arbeiten du musst mit den
Kindern arbeiten muss an den Schulen
arbeiten es geht nicht das ist wie an
der Schule meine Sohnes war also
halbwegs liberal habe ich gesagt mein
Sohn geht in Kreuzberg mal schön in die
in die nahe Schule richtig schön keine
Privatschule und dann war er einer von
zwei deutschen Jungs in der Klasse waren
Araber und Türken hier geboren ganz
liebe Kinder in der Schule hatte mein
Sohn ganz viele Freunde aber danach
nicht einen mehr die sind in die
Koranschule gegangen die waren die
durfte nicht zu denen mit nach Hause und
das darf nicht passieren wir müssen mit
den Kindern arbeiten wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die Schulen anders bei der
Politik reden Sie mit den falschen
passiert das mit wem reden sie wird die
Tipps es ist tatsächlich extrem schwer
es gibt eben nicht die Vertreter des
Islam es gibt übrigens auch schon beim
Thema politischer Islam große
Meinungsunterschiede was ist denn das
also auch große Unklarheit viele
definitorischen Unschärfen werden das
mal auf dem Parteitag diskutiert genau
dieses Verbot und dann gab es dann auch
gleich die Frage ja wen genau meinst Du
und wie grenzt du das ab am Ende ist
glaube ich Aufklärung der Schlüssel muss
erstmal klar sein mit welchen Strukturen
haben wir es eigentlich zu tun
intensiver damit beschäftigen die sind
sich da auch klar natürlich haben wir
natürlich haben wir Ansprechpartner aber
ich kann sagen wie ich das mache ich
beschäftige mich nicht täglich damit
sondern kommen Anfragen auf dem Tisch
hey Mensch da fehlt nur noch ein
Vertreter der CDU auf dem Podium im
Verein XY so und das sagt mir erstens
die Vertreter der anderen Parteien sind
hingegangen ohne nachzufragen ich habe
danach gefragt ist das ein Verein wo man
hingehen kann Antwort Finger weg werden
vom Verfassungsschutz beobachtet große
beobachtet so die Frage stellen aber
viele andere schon gar nicht und und da
fängt das kann und bei der Frage wie
geht man damit um ja an den Schulen das
ist der gleiche Punkt wie eben wenn wir
nicht an den Schulen anfangen auch über
genau dieses Thema zu sprechen und
deutlich zu machen das ist eine Gefahr
für euch alle für uns alle für unser
Zusammenleben aus folgenden Gründen das
was in diesen Moscheen oder toleriert
wird das ist nicht akzeptabel für eine
freiheitliche demokratische Grundordnung
die Finanzierung aus dem Ausland ist
nicht akzeptabel für eine Grundordnung
wie die unsere und das muss man auch
klar benennen dürfen aber richtig ist
die Auseinandersetzungen die dann
anschließend stattfinden die wir kennen
überhaupt keine Rücksicht die ich habe
ja viel zu tun auch mit einer Imamen die
ein Versuch dann Liberalen Islam in
Berlin zu leben die hat die gleiche
Schutzstufe vatisch ist und die mit
dieser Initiative brutal ausgegrenzt von
ihr
und die hat den gleichen Schutz stand
vorstellen aber ist das nicht ein Beweis
dafür dass diese Reformbewegungen jetzt
einer Frau attisch die versuchte Islam
und Homosexualität in irgendwie in
wie soll man sagen dass das nicht im
Widerspruch steht ja dass die
Homosexuellen Feindlichkeit
Antisemitismus und so weiter abgebaut
wird dass sie die Anfeindungen von den
eigenen Leuten bekommt und von den
eigenen Leuten gefährdet wird zeigt ja
dass das dass diese Initiativen keine
Zuspruch in der unter der Mehrheit der
Muslime jetzt zum Beispiel jetzt in
Berlin sind wichtig also
glauben Sie nicht das ist eine Art
Aufklärung im Islam geben kann
das eine Art Erneuerung der Stadt finden
kann damit hat der Zermatt glaubt genau
das erlaubt dann kommt er zu einem
lieber rein europäischen Islam glaube
ich ehrlich gesagt nicht wenn ich ganz
ehrlich bin und ich denke Politiker
suchen sich da oft so Partner jetzt wird
oder Frau sedanaktisch und zeigen sich
mit ihnen machen Fotos und sagen ja wir
haben jetzt die Initiative und wir
unterstützen sie aber jetzt die Frage
konkret wie viele Moslems gegen den in
die Moschee von zeldanatisch wo eine
Frau vorbetet oder ein Homosexueller
Imam und ich kann Ihnen sagen dass die
andere Moscheen voll sind und dass man
in ganz Berlin ich weiß nicht wie viel
Muslime Berlin hat eine Handvoll Leute
dort hingehen und sehe dann optisch
nachweislich von den eigenen
Glaubensgeschwistern bedroht wird und
deswegen sage ich ganz ehrlich ich kann
nicht mehr ich kann wirklich ich kann
nicht wirklich mehr daran glauben weil
die Realität ist einfach eine andere ich
würde es mir wünschen dass die meisten
Muslime in Deutschland sagen ja und wir
wollen den Islam reformieren und so
weiter aber ich sehe einfach überhaupt
nicht die Bereitschaft und wegen dem
Thema auch linke Heuchelei mein ich
finde das Beispiel jetzt Iran und das
islamische Zentrum in Hamburg ein gutes
Beispiel
Jahrzehnte lang hat man es gefördert
geduldet der Bürgermeister damals
Hamburgs Bürgermeister Olaf Scholz jetzt
in der Bundeskanzler hat sich dort
ablichten lassen ja mit mit dem
Regenschirm und irgendwelchen Eier
toller ist und das hat man alles
unterstützt und jetzt mit dem mit der
mit dem Aufständen im Iran sagt man oh
nee wir wollen jetzt mit der radikalen
Moschee nichts mehr zu tun haben oder
sie sieht man wie wie opportunistisch
viele Parteien und Politiker sich da
verhalten und Strukturen die sie
Jahrzehnte lang gefördert haben und und
quasi damit Verantwortung tragen dann
plötzlich ablehnen weil sie merken jetzt
wird ein anderer Wind und jetzt gibt's
deine positionsbewegung und die Frauen
im Iran reißen sich die Kopftücher
runter und abseits dieser dieser
populistischen Politik müssen einfach
mal
grundlegend gewisse Maßnahmen getroffen
werden weil die Situation eben immer
immer über die Sand auch wird
14.2 wird die Wahl wiederholt und da
stecken sie Zwölfter zweiter und da
stecken sie mittendrin gerade ja früher
ein bisschen auf der Straße aber sie
haben auch ein wichtiges Thema heute
mitgebracht die Grünen würden am
liebsten die Innenstädte autofrei machen
zumindest verbrennerfrei aber autofrei
vielleicht auf lange Sicht sie sagen das
ist aber jetzt im Wahlkampf eine reine
Polemik das ist ihr Thema Helge
wir haben es in Berlin damit zu tun dass
das grüne verkehrspolitische Programm
insgesamt nur heißen kann Wege zum
Stillstand da geht's ja nicht nur um die
Frage die Innenstadt von Autos
freizuhalten wir haben eine
Verkehrssituation von den Grünen in
Berlin die um jeden Preis 500 Meter
Straße hier in der Nähe in der
Friedrichstraße sperren will und sich
nicht darum kümmert das U-Bahnen nicht
mehr fahren am gleichen Tag sind zwei
ganz wichtige U-Bahn Strecken hier in
Berlin gesperrt worden indem sie die
Straße gesperrt hat wir haben ein
Problem mit ganz anderen Verkehrsträgern
die S-Bahn der Zentrale Tunnel ist
gesperrt die verkehrsinatorin kümmert
sich nicht darum dass dieses Baustellen
Chaos Gehalt wird und selbst im
Luftverkehr sieht so aus dass bald
Provinz Flughafen mehr internationale
Verbindungen hat als Berlin also
insofern kann ich nur sagen dieses
stillstandsprogramm das muss Enden das
ist das Grundproblem grüner Politik und
zum Thema Elektromobilität keiner von
uns hat was dagegen elektrisch zu fahren
aber wenn die Infrastruktur nicht da ist
dann ist die Kernaussage doch man will
das Auto gar nicht in der Stadt und da
muss man sich mal einfach Berlin
umschauen viele viele Menschen sind
überhaupt darauf angewiesen um sich
bewegen zu können da gibt es keine
U-Bahn da gibt es keine S-Bahn und davor
die Augen zu verschließen das ist grüne
Realitätsverweigerung
freie Bürger ist sozusagen das Motto so
ein bisschen Peter glaubst du das wird
viele für ein Kreuzchen bewegen ist das
auch ein Thema das bei dir so ein
bisschen ins Herz trifft ich wohne in
Kreuzberg bei mir bei mir sind also
jetzt mal einfach nur aus dem Hauptstadt
leben das ist auch etwas was glaube ich
noch woanders Brot bei mir um um die
Ecke da wo der nutzius sitzt da sind
zwei Friedhöfe der nunius sitzt neben
der Kirche und dann ist da noch eine
Laubenkolonie unter packten immer die
Handwerker Autos der packten die Leute
mit den Marktständen die konnten da ganz
in Ruhe kurz vor der Polizei alles
abstellen das Ding ist schon so eine
anwohnerparkzone gemacht von dem Männer
liegen tote das ist ein anwohnerparkzone
jetzt kann da niemand mehr was abstellen
was ist die Folge dass die Autos jetzt
woanders stehen nämlich in den
Wohngebieten und die Parkplätze
wegnehmen weil die Leuten vor der
Haustür dann werden Parkplätze von fast
über Nacht handstreichartig den ganzen
Straßen abgeschafft dann gibt es eine
Tempo 30 Zone in einer Tempo 30 Zone
darfst du keine extra Fahrradstraße
anlegen dann wird Tempo 30 aufgehoben
der Fahrradweg wird durchgebaut
es ist eine Politik die wild mit
Verboten arbeiten die will die Menschen
in einen Korsett reinzwingen so kann
Foto darf Politik nicht funktionieren
zwar nirgends auf der auf der Welt man
hat den Bürgern ein Angebot zu machen
und mir die freie Wahl zu lassen nicht
freie Fahrt für freie Bürger sondern
freie Wahl für freie Bürgerschaft
Angebote die attraktiv sind die es mir
ermöglichen auf das Auto an bestimmten
Sachen zu verzichten das ist Politik so
muss Politik funktionieren die ist
nämlich für die Bürger und nicht gegen
die Bürger da und Politiker der muss
Gesetz diese Ausführen der hat eine
Verwaltung sicher zuzustellen und die
Sicherheit und die Ordnung
sicherzustellen aber er ist nicht der
Volkserzieher wir sind nicht in der DDR
zu vorher waren sie sicherlich unbedingt
immer eins ja wir sind Exportnationen
Autos das ist ganz große Thema in
Deutschland glauben Sie sie können es
irgendwie beziffern sollten wir jetzt
mal so weit denken dass wir sagen in
Städte frei von Autos immer noch
Elektromobilität was glauben Sie wie
viele Arbeitsplätze könnten uns da auch
verloren gehen die Frage
Elektromobilität lassen wir mal außen
vor dass ein großes Streit Thema ich bin
da sehr skeptisch im übrigen aber
ein anderer Punkt ist ja auch sehr
interessant und zwar man stellt sich vor
Sie haben das erwähnt ähm wir wollen
keine Autos mehr aber die Idee dahinter
ist doch ich mache das andere nicht
attraktiv sondern das andere mache ich
schlechter und nur so funktioniert ich
habe vor ich weiß nicht zwei Jahren mal
gelesen von einem Stadtrat in Berlin in
Friedrichshain kreuzbergmeister
geschrieben er musste leider jetzt mal
das Auto nehmen um zum Rathaus zu kommen
und er hat gemerkt er kommt so viel
besser dahin und die Schlussfolgerung
die er gezogen hat die war klasse er
sagte nämlich
ja Autofahren muss unattraktiver werden
nicht dass nicht die öffentlichen
Nahverkehrsmittel müssen besser werden
und das ist aber letztendlich die
Quintessenz des Sozialismus wir können
es nicht für alle gut machen wir machen
für alle schlecht ja
der schönste Zeitpunkt um herzlichen
Dank zu sagen an meine Gäste heute Abend
und herzlichen Dank an sie fürs
zuschauen wir sehen uns morgen wieder
bei 8:15 Uhr bis dann
[Musik]